i i try and read uh news from both sides
of the political aisle uh not to find
the one i agree with but i want to
understand how it's being reported i
want to know the different narratives
that are being told so that i can
understand those narratives so i can
speak to those narratives i can learn
those narratives
and find hypocrisy on both sides by the
way
um i think that the one the one mistake
that we all fall into
is to decide that the ones that i agree
with are right and the ones that i
disagree with are wrong
um and this this binary notion of right
versus wrong um is is what's gotten us
into this into this mess in the first
place um life is not so so so so black
and white in no respect uh it's nuanced
and gray and complicated and messy and
to to understand that we are hypocrites
in our own opinions um and so is the
other side and simply pointing out the
hypocrisy of the other side is of no
help whatsoever what's more important is
to point out our own hypocrisy
um and to try and understand that like i
said it's a worthy rivalry thing right
it's not trying to dominate or be right
but it's rather trying to improve and to
grow um and and so one of the things
that i default to are values
um
i'm very proud of the fact that some of
my friendships are with people who have
very very very different
uh political points of view um who we
voted very very differently in political
elections
um and we can go to blows uh talking
about some of the things that the
government is uh is deciding whether we
agree or disagree with it um but at the
end of the day uh their values are are
like mine
and we and we believe in taking care of
each other and we believe in looking out
for each other and at the end of the day
more than their politics they're my
friend
um and i learned this lesson the hard
way where i was walking uh i was going
for a walk with a friend who has very
different political views than me
and she said something and i i
definitely thought it and i fear i may
have said it how can you be so stupid
and i realized i just called my friend
stupid and she completely got angry at
me not because i disagreed with her it's
because i judged her and insulted her
and she know what she was 100 right and
what i had to learn in that moment was
to listen
was to replace my judgment with
curiosity
and to understand where her point of
view comes from and that i and that the
more curious i became to understand that
there were actually things that we did
agree upon and though we may not have
agreed upon everything there we actually
could find common ground and that common
ground always boiled down to our values
and the more that i got good at
listening to her
she actually we became much more open to
listening to me
and so as opposed to me hammering my
opinion at her
we started to have conversations and so
i think when you go to a values level
politics becomes secondary but when we
let go of our values then all we have is
the politics which is upsetting